um and so there's this common
misconception that you're not
the kid that carries the backpack
anymore i still think you're the kid
that loves basketball and carry a
backpack yeah but
over the course of the years your
answers
to the me how you deal with the media
has changed
why is that is that just who you grew
into as that because of the way they act
with certain [ __ ] where did that
i felt like the media knew more than me
i almost had them on a pedestal of like
they got more history knowledge of the
game they more experience than me in
this area of the nba so once i started
to get more experience and realize like
oh no
they can never be
what i am or know what i know
or understand it the way i understand it
some of the questions you know they
didn't seem so intelligent to me anymore
people wanted to praise me more than i
liked or
hate me more than i like make a big deal
out of so much other [ __ ] i was just
like you know this game is simple to me
so some of the stuff that y'all asking
really doesn't move me the way it used
to i just